[Music]
I'm Wylie Dufresne and we are here at
Gustavus and coffee and waves or
Brooklyn we have 12 different doughnuts
that we serve right now different
flavors some are sugar summer glazed
I've come by my donut love honestly I
think my great-grandfather was a donut
maker in Central Falls Rhode Island and
I ate a lot of doughnuts as a kid and
for me it's about childhood about my
childhood memories tips that still
resonate with me today it's a pretty
standard profit we started with flour
baking powder and sugar in salt and
nutmeg we mix that all together we then
fold in our butter and then we add our
egg yolks and our milk we blend that
together into a batter we let that
batter rest for a period of time and
then we load that batter into the robot
the robot does a good job of dropping
the donut in a nice ring and it floats
downstream sort of in the spirit of the
lazy river at the halfway point it flips
them over for us and then once the
donuts come out and they've cooled a
little bit we blazing and we have about
11 different glazes that we use I think
when you look at our donuts you can
immediately say okay that's it let's do
some and it looks like these and our
flavors I think our flavors are are what
helps you realize you're having you know
one of our Delma
it's just something I want to do for a
long time I think it's a great
opportunity for creativity it's a great
up which you need to have some fun and
be playful and we tend to be sort of
endlessly tinkering with things and
tweaking and trying to make it better
today than it was yesterday
[Music]